I love the I love you guys so much I
could say whatever I want
that's how I feel about it I love you so
much
that I can just say whatever I want and
I feel like there's gonna be love at the
end of it and that's why and that's why
I want to express to you how grateful I
am for this podcast I think that we're
doing real well as a group and a family
you know yeah and and then tomorrow
we're celebrating our one-year with with
15 of our listeners that we've had
picked we hand-picked them yes and then
Wednesday Carla is going to the lady in
America premiere with me and then this
weekend I'm at the Oxnard lovely live
and I want to see everyone there pack it
out pack it out this week it's a new
club right yeah I gotta figure out a way
here's the thing I also have to figure
out a way to only take photos with Tiger
belly people and let the rest of them go
raw your process is where this is where
it's difficult for you yeah this then
then you tell them because I tried that
Georgia has a pink dick thing everyone
does it it's just too many people coming
up to me saying George is a pink dick
and I'm like that's a little weird
look guys I've explained to other people
that no I had this guy George he's my
producer and he has a pink dick the best
way to do it is to tell your family if
you're a tiger belly listener stay after
the show
just sit don't rush to go out and make
him go no not all there's there's about
20 minutes before the club actually
kicks you out so there's always
stragglers there there are some people
who immediately go to the lobby to see
if Bobby doesn't meet and greet but he
he never does meet and greets he usually
just runs in the back and we go home so
what I usually do as I look at the
stragglers who are smart enough to stay
and they leisurely flagged me down and
then they get the picture I usually take
him to the greenroom - yeah I got to
figure out a way because I want to say
hi to Tiger Billy people and I at the
Comedy Store - there was a kid last
night young cute good-looking kid amen I
love Tiger belly and I'm a huge fan and
he just seemed like he really loves it
yeah and I took my time whenever that
happens especially with Tiger
I take my time you know I'm not I mean
I'm grateful for people that to buy
tickets who don't listen to the podcast
but there's some a weirder connection I
have with people that do because I I
think they know you more they know their
real Bobby not just as a as a TV guy you
know
[Music]